it's a hard-knock life for us it's a
hard-knock life for us some some I've
got box something something it really
rocks welcome to the grand finale of the
sour patch saga the war between me and
mr. patch himself I am falling they mr.
patch and all of his underlings his or
her I'm no judge have deemed me worthy
of their time and attention and they
have sent me a personalised box they
recognize that I am the sour patch
review Channel and now I get a bigger
box full of presents and goodies I
honestly have no idea what's in here but
if I had to imagine it's a lifetime
supply of Sour Patch Kids in my favorite
flavour it's 12 new pairs of shoes whoo
all in my favorite colors and just what
red so I'm gonna open this I'm gonna sit
down isn't big a box of this magnitude
requires a precision tool
[Music]
I don't know what sons growing and hyung
requires a precision tool please be a
nice knife hold on hold on hold on to
get you I'm gonna get you and he's like
oh hey Oh Jews no I got a bottle of
wines here hey that's where I died no
trust me with a knife except I'm an
expert I'm an expert is what I said as a
kid right before I always hurt myself
but what before I stuck my hand in a bee
bush a bush full of bees we didn't have
you know games to play we played with
the bee Bush as a kid I said to my
brother I'm an expert did you think you
were an expert well I thought if I said
that it might have some effect and then
I stuck my hand in the bush I don't know
confidence has gotten you a long way
it's it's confidence
anyway I'm an expert Sam so I don't know
what particular order it's gonna be in
it's just like a box so oh my god
it's just open is this supposed to be
open oh my god it's a sealed bag and
they use blue as packing peanuts that is
my favorite flavor I mean I'm not gonna
touch a single goddamn one of these no
way in hell I'm never gonna eat these
all right Han can you smell the sour
patch in the air
it's a letter I've not read this letter
I have not seen a single thing in here
I'm ready for an apology a certificate
of transfer of ownership of the company
into my name three new products all
markiplier themed and then a giant sour
patch with a big big mustache at the
bottom of this letter all right mark
okay start they got my name in here
didn't like our first box thought it
wasn't special enough there right so far
not custom enough to your precious taste
right once again let's try again shall
we
didn't like the plastic wrapping on our
individually wrapped Sour Patch Kids
gone thank you wanted blue instead of
our Curry seven inspired green and pink
pack blue it is thank you
we even threw in a Funko pop cuz we know
how much you love dolls
mwah-ha-ha-ha oh yes or sour
we are the sour patch kids after are
they mad at me
however you know us we're sour than
sweet so once you make it through the
sour there's a pretty sweet surprise
waiting there's a bomb or whatever is at
the bottom of this box is going to kill
me
enjoy signed mr. patch well not signed
it just typed PS we have to say it cuz
you know the feds if you do post about
what we sent you please let the good
people know that it was a gift from your
friends and sour patch kids by saying
something like sour patch kids just gave
me
everyone knows who doesn't get what's
going on here who do you think sent me
this you think my mom wrote this letter
or orchestrated this whole thing just to
make it look like I'm conversing with
the sour patch kids company which would
be a great bit mom but I think people
might think people know I think it's
more of an insult to all the other
influencers
do that so what are their fans think
they think this just showed up at their
door that somehow they magically went to
a store and got specific red and pink or
whatever pink and green it looks I just
want to hold of it okay anyway Sour
Patch Kids
hashtag and it's but it's not though I'm
not not getting any money for it I'm not
being paid for this in any way shape or
form new five nights at Freddy's merch
cloak brand calm can't see it plus my
magic Freddy
alright so let's let's start to dive in
first off my I'm so happy this already
makes it better I know that there's like
sarcasm is dripping out of this box
sarcasm is raining out of the box
however this actually makes me happy
here this is very nice I am super about
this I am NOT super about this
especially nowadays and I will wash my
hands before I consume anything in this
box this is okay that's not okay
and there's a Funko pop you do love
dolls yeah
I am a collectibles kind of guy everyone
knows this unless there was one of me
and then suddenly I would love them I
mean still love them so until that day
comes I will stick to the truth which is
that I love them alright what else is
here there's a giant it's it's a big
please really in here what is this wait
a minute what what the hell what the
hell ah if I'm not mistaken this is my
icon made out of Sour Patch Kids
it smells so sugary I can smell like the
candy wafting off the eyes are a little
scary
okay now actually oh wait no the eyes
are up here I thought this was just like
a hollow dot I know yeah
that's crazy I don't know what those are
made out of little genuinely this is all
sour patch kids I don't know what if
these are still cuz I don't think they
have a purple and I definitely don't
have a white no those are sad patch kids
oh those are sour patch kids that were
coming out from place sideways it's all
sour patch kids that's actually really
cool that is sweet
that's really nice that's so crazy
it's dripping sugar everywhere but
that's really cool damn just pretty cool
do you know that honestly that's really
nice Thank You mr. patch I consider our
feud settled and as a last moat of good
faith between us
I should have sleeping bag of cocaine oh
I will try the bag of blue cuz at the
end of the day this is what's all about
and until the sour patch cream cheese
comes out which apparently is a
that's happening literally there's they
tweeted about it this is what it's all
about the candy all this crap is about
candy Emily that is good and it's good
the flavor is great
I love blue raspberry it's not a real
flavor very artificial but I don't care
a little bit however mr. patch you just
made me break my fast I am doing
intermittent fasting I can't eat for
another four hours and you just forced
me to ruin all the progress I have
intermittent fasting how dare you sir
ma'am ma'am sir yeah it doesn't matter
they're delicious moral the story is if
you yell at someone long enough they'll
send you a gift no [ __ ] missile
you know you're being very sour and then
sweet what do you say
Hey